et hier à conques s'appelle copie commis
qui a dévoilé que rémi gaillard aurait
repris les sketchs du comique
britannique d'hommes joly alors on va
regarder la comparaison mais rémy a
répondu et je trouve que ça moi je
trouve que ça sa réponse me va vous
allez nous dire si elle vous va ou pas
regardez le petit montage
alors certes il fait ça avec l'inde
comica on en a déjà parlé
rémi gaillard a répondu il a dit j'ai
effectivement fait un clin d'oeil à
domme joly donc j'adore le travail et
son programme
tu es gaap et y vit avec la vidéo animal
planet publié en janvier 2016 ou celle
du mafieux dans le parking mais ça
s'arrête là il se trouve que l'on va
tourner une vidéo ensemble avec celui
qu'on m'accuse de plagier il m'a même
proposé de venir à montpellier alors
qu'il fonde en pensez mais je trouve que
la caméra cachée existe depuis la nuit
des temps
jean-yves vous en avait fait l'un ma
fille également il ya des bases en
caméra cachée et après c'est la mise en
scène qui se différencient
particulièrement la rémi gaillard a dit
que c'était un clin d'oeil
effectivement on peut rendre hommage
parfois lorsque nargis de choses moi je
suis là doré milliards vous savez il est
très drôle oui mathieu non quand on rend
hommage
on cite ses sources absolument car dont
il ne fait pas du tout et ça djamel que
j'adore je pas créteil c'est un génie
mais qu'en de pareilles on aime feuille
d'or attend juste un petit mot il abuse
te dit lui aussi c'est un hommage quand
on aime des courriers qu'américain alors
on les sites mais aussi en amont si
jamel et gad elmaleh des sites donc très
bien en tous les cas là c'est pas du
tout un hommage
il a pompé des bad il ya eu un loupé au
lycée alors même avec vous qui faites
beaucoup de caméras et j'ai dit là bas
non mais c'est vrai j'aimerais que j'ai
ouvert ma gueule ça va
non mais là c'est vrai c'est vrai quand
je cours je me suis fait bobo chaque
fois sur des tonnes d'histoires tutoie
vous bordel
non c'est vrai je suis d'accord avec
mathieu on doit citer ses sources
quand dans le comics ou dans n'importe
quelle saison science alors les
scientifiques c'est pareil il ya les
brevets il ya tout ça c'est la même
chose maintenant après est-ce que tu
dois passer une dimension au dessus
c'est ça le truc certes tu vois quelque
chose qui te fait m'arrête envie de loin
au pied à l'asmo là tu mets la barre au
dessus tu vas dix fois plus loin
maintenant maintenant on sait pétain
hasard le truc c'est que ça a été fait
en 2000 rendre hommage 13 ans après
ouais c'est bien il y aurait peut-être
qu'elle lui rende hommage
quelques années avant la fin n'ont alors
pas tels qu'ils ont eu la même idée
aussi mais il a fait combien 150 vidéos
soit sur plus que ça avait nettement il
y en a deux qui se ressemblent contexte
agir maintenant a dit j'en ai piqué 2 on
peut s'inspirer
nous on s'inspire bien de jeux qui sont
faits à l'étranger ici on le dit même
souvent déjà caché non mais non ben il
est donc ça fait un carton en
afghanistan voilà on l'a jamais dit ici
voilà le jour où le dis dans mes
céréales géraldine maillet une somme qui
leur est dû le dire effectivement je
suis d'accord avec mathieu même si la
côte de veau se trouve ça n'enlève rien
à son talent dit la vérité e gilles moi
je commence à être troublé parce que là
c'est vrai qu'il ya plusieurs vidéos
c'est exactement la même chose l'anglais
dit j'ai essayé de le joindre il m'a
jamais répondu
il faudrait que rémi gaillard quand même
s'expliquer quercy alors été sauvés au
téléphone un parent et in fine qui
disent très récemment mais parce que
l'anglais au bout d'un moment a dit
c'est plus possible alors à travers oger
vous vous citez vos sources parfois est
ce que vous vous inspirez dans vos
spectacles de
d'autres comiques ou très attention je
connais bien non mais moi ça m'est pas
ça m'est jamais arrivé de voir un truc
est de me dire je vais faire exactement
la même chose et j'espère que personne
va s'en rendre compte
non mais alors on aime bien avoir une
idée à moi donc j'ai pas dis parfois il
ya des hasards parfois les dites rares
fois je pense que on peut aussi que les
idéal vol comme exactement j'ai lu un
bouquin ou l aléna elle expliqué sur la
créativité comme ça que les idées de
plusieurs endroits exacts même temps bon
là il ya 13 ans d'écart donc un peu
bizarre mais valéo volé pendant 13 ans